In short, yes, a man can test positive if
he pees on a pregnancy tester.
How?
What a pregnancy test looks for is the presence
of elevated levels of the hormone beta human
chorionic gonadotropin (hCG).
There are certain types of testicular cancers
that also release this hormone.
Thus, if a man has elevated levels of hCG,
he could have testicular cancer resulting
in a positive pregnancy test.
The opposite is not true; just because you’re
a guy and you test negative on a pregnancy
test, it doesn’t mean you’re cancer free
as not all testicular tumors secrete this
hormone.
Interestingly, several other types of tumors
also secrete hCG.
So sit back, read on, and find out everything
you didn’t think you needed to know about
hCG.
Human chorionic gonadotropins main purpose
in pregnancy is to keep the lining of the
uterus (endometrium) thick during the first
trimester.
It does this by promoting the secretion of
another hormone, progesterone, by the ovaries.
Just prior to ovulation, the ovaries naturally
produce progesterone.
This does several things- it slightly elevates
the body temperature; it makes the uterus
muscles less likely to contract; and it helps
create more mucus in the vagina.
This all helps keep the sperm alive and more
likely to reach the egg.
If progesterone levels were to drop off, the
lining of the uterus is thinned by shedding.
After around week 20 of pregnancy, the placenta
produces steroid hormones to diminish the
role of hCG and thereby progesterone.
the-role-of-recombinant-hcg-in-ivf-3-638So
what about hCG and cancer?
It can be released by several types of cancer
tumors such as cancers involving the ovaries,
stomach, lungs, and testes.
Cancers involving the liver, mutated epithelial
cells, and those involving the endocrine (hormonal)
system and nervous system are also associated
with hCG release.
Finally, this hormone is typically found in
extremely high levels in patients suffering
kidney failure.
As mentioned before, a negative pregnancy
test doesn’t mean one is cancer free.
There are several types of testicular cancers
and not all produce elevated levels of hCG.
Lumped into two categories, they’re known
as seminomas and non-seminomas.
These types of cancers also produce other
markers that aren’t picked up by pregnancy
tests, such as alpha-fetaprotein and lactate
dehydrogenase.
The only type that always gives off hCG is
known as Choriocarcinoma.
In fact, only 20%-40% of seminomas and 40%-50%
of non-seminomas give off elevated levels
of hCG.
HCG has many other uses than testing for pregnancy.
Since it’s been known to cause ovulation
within 48 hours after injection, some doctors
use this method of hormone therapy prior to
attempting in vitro fertilization.
Beyond this, because it can help produce testosterone,
bodybuilders who take steroids have been known
to take hCG as a supplement.
This also helps prevent some of certain steroids’
long term side effects, like shrinking testicles.
You will also often read that hCG therapy
will help with weight loss, but numerous studies
have shown this notion to be absolutely false.
shutterstock_229502134So to sum up- yes, men
can test positive on pregnancy tests and if
you do, you should immediately head on down
to your local clinic and find out if you have
cancer.
Beyond pregnancy tests, common signs and symptoms
of testicular cancer include: any lump felt
on the testicle; any testicle enlargement,
change in shape, or size irregularities; pain
or discomfort in the scrotum or testicle;
a dull ache or sense of pressure in the lower
back or abdomen; a feeling of heaviness or
fullness in the scrotum; and enlargement or
tenderness of the breasts.
The good news for those who are particularly
vigilant about such signs is that testicular
cancer is one of the most curable forms of
cancer there is.
The 5 year survival rates are 99% if localized,
meaning the cancer is still only in the testicle;
96% if regional, meaning the cancer is found
in the testicle and surrounding lymph nodes
or tissues; and 73% if the cancer has spread
to the organs or lymph nodes away from the
tumor.
While 73% isn’t bad, relatively speaking,
99 out of 100 is much better, so be sure to
check often!